um underneath that i'd love to make this
little subheading which is exact values
now some of you will have encountered
these in year 10
but some of you will not have so i'm
going to treat this as kind of new
and if you're like oh no i'm familiar
with this then you'll be able to zip
through this pretty quickly
okay with your calculator in hand what
you will have noticed
is that often um say for example if we
went back and put sine of 53
back into your calculator not sine of
53.1 blah blah blah
just put in sine 53 and press equals
right
what you'll get is some decimal
expansion that just seems to go on
forever did you notice that what did you
get
zero point sign of 53 degrees zero point
seven nine eight right et cetera so you
notice this close to 0.8
because that's the exact but i didn't
ask you to put in the exact one right
so you always get this when you're
putting in angles into sine cos or tan
you get all this weird decimal stuff
right
except there are some very particular
angles that will give you not some
weird approximate expansion but
something exact
and that's what i want to help us
understand there's a few sets of exact
values that are going to go along with
these
triangles here that will help you so can
you help me draw a right angled triangle
and make sure it's a bit taller than it
is wide and this one you can see it's
the same height as it is
wide but this one make it a bit taller
and what we're going to put in here
are a couple of particular angles that
will give us nice values
here are the angles that we want
calculator is still in hand
clear where it says sine 53 and instead
i want you to type in
sine 30. what does it tell you
sine 30 degrees what's it tell you 0.5
it gives you exactly
1 over 2. now remembering that we've
just done it three times right
remembering that sine is opposite on
hypotenuse right
what this tells us is there's some
triangle with 30 degrees in it
where opposite on hypotenuse will
simplify to 1 over 2.
maybe it's like 5 over 10 or 13 over 26
but once you simplify it
you get 1 over 2. okay now this is the
triangle that i've asked you to
construct
here if i were to put c up in this top
corner here you've got a smaller angle
if that were 30 degrees and i didn't ask
you to do this with a protractor so
it probably will not be exactly 30 but
it'll be close
sine 30 being opposite on hypotenuse
which sides are those
in my triangle can you describe them to
me which one's the one
it's the one yeah right down here on the
bottom so this would be
a one and the hypotenuse of course is
opposite the
right angle so that would make this one
i guess
two okay now i got mentioned before um
our good main pythagoras will help us
work out what this last side is
right let's go ahead and do this now if
i call this last side say
x right what equation can i write that
relates
x and one and two
with pythagoras help me out yeah go
ahead two squared minus one squared
equals
x squared two squared one squared
x squared okay so you've gone to like
the direct version which is very nice
um if we were to do the kind of like
vanilla version of pythagoras we would
say
the squares of the two shorter sides you
add them up and you get the square of
the hypotenuse do you agree
if i just rearrange this i get what you
just mentioned before if i
subtract 1 squared from both sides
you get x squared is that okay you can
see what i've done to both sides
that tells you x squared is what
three thank you i can do two squared in
my head i can do one square in my head
so because this is going to give us um
a nice answer for x and x is just the
length so i don't need the negative one
i get the square root of three is that
okay with you and i should say
it's a length so that's why i disregard
one of the solutions so
you can get rid of that you can call
this
root three over here now the reason this
is handy is because now i know
not just sine thirty equals a half i can
say what cos 30 is
right we've got the triangle right
cos is which ratio can you give me the
answer right it's the ratio of
adjacent on hypotenuse which therefore
is root three
divided by two you've got your
calculator there right um with the
person next to you i want one of you to
go ahead and put in root three divided
by two
and then the person the other alternate
person go ahead and put cos of 30
degrees
do we get the same answer
so we're putting in someone is putting
in cos of 30 degrees get an answer
the other person is putting in root
three divided by two getting an answer
zero point eight six blah blah blah blah
you'll get very familiar with that
number actually because you'll see it
over and over again
so what we've got is not just an exact
value for sine but an exact value for
cos of 30. you could do an exact value
for
10 couldn't you right what do we got cos
30 degrees is root 3 on 2 so what's 10
of 30. yeah opposite
on adjacent can you check that for me as
well right 10 or 30 degrees
and 1 root 3 is what we think it's equal
to
so make sure someone else types in one
divided by root three it checks out what
is it by the way
roughly 0.577 so you'll see that and
you'll now
start to you'll get more familiar
recognizing okay so these three here
what we call the exact values
for the trigonometric ratios of 30
degrees but you can see
on top of these three we've actually got
three more for free
if you have a look back at that triangle
and if you can tell me what's the
most obvious missing piece of
information on the triangle
the other angle i've got all three sides
and then i've got this angle missing
down here
right now this is just the complement of
30 which by the way
is why cosine is called cosine let's
think about this right uh let's do
cos of 60 degrees what's it equal to
have a look at the triangle don't even
go to your calculator cos of 60 here's
60.
cos is adjacent
on hypotenuse it's one over two doesn't
that look
suspicious right it's because 30 and 60
are
complementary hence the complement of
sine what about you could even
tell me without looking at the triangle
now right what's sine of 30
oh sorry sorry sine of 30. sine of 60 is
what we're up to
it's root 3 on 2 because it's the
complement and you can just confirm that
by saying oh look
opposite on hypotenuse yeah so what did
we just say root 3
on 2k and tell me what tan of 60 is
10 to 60 you have to look probably back
in the triangle for this one root 3 over
1
x root 3 over 1 which the over one
doesn't do anything so you've got these
okay
so completely jot them down for me like
i said some of you will have encountered
these
in year 10 but others of you this is the
first time you're seeing it so
this here this set of exact values is
phenomenally useful
30 60. and from here
we can actually draw one other triangle
um i i wonder if you've already done
this one here
can you see it's kind of isosceles
looking isosceles that was on purpose
isosceles so if i've got two equal sides
that are the shorter sides right one and
one again with pythagoras and i wonder
if you can do this part in your head
you might be able to help me work out
what the hypotenuse is
this is 1 1 so 1 squared plus 1 squared
is hypotenuse squared so i just want the
hypotenuse so i have to take the square
root
which gives me root 2.
now that's using pythagoras that gives
me all the signs but i need angles right
this is a right angle triangle and i've
said these isosceles so what can you
tell me about these
corner angles they're going to be 45-45
that's the only way you'll get
180 degrees as your angle sum does that
make sense so let's go ahead and put in
45 degrees in each one
45 here and 45
here okay now we got all of these exact
values
out of this one triangle we've got a few
exact values out of here
as well except there's um they're quite
easy to work out
sine of 45 degrees what is that in this
triangle
yeah it doesn't matter which one because
they're both 45 you go opposite
on hypotenuse so you get one on root two
and because mathematicians love being
lazy they love this guess what comes
along for the ride
because of 45 it's also equal to
1 on root 2 just to go back to the idea
before
that is because 45 is its own
complement do you see that so the sign
and the complement of sine
will be the same there's one last what's
the one i'm missing one last ratio in
here
tan very good i think i was doing that
in blue tan of 45
that's opposite on adjacent so in this
triangle it is
one over one which is one now when i was
i'm old enough now i'm like more than
double your age
when i was your age the first thing i
did in every single maths exam from year
11 onwards was
i drew this triangle and that triangle
on the front of my paper
i didn't even need to know what
questions are coming out i was
definitely going to use these right
students did this so much that nessa was
like huh it looks like you um
looks like you like doing that so it
seems like
it might be helpful to you if we kind of
cut out the middleman
who's got their copy of the reference
sheet nearby on hand
anyone got it have you printed it out
did you get one at the start of the year
potentially okay the reason why it's
useful by the way is that
the reference sheet is no use to you if
you don't know where things are on it
right if you're like ah there's a thing
there don't know where it is you'll
spend as much time finding the thing
as using it right so i'm going to show
you where something is now here's the
first page
of the reference sheet right if you just
scroll a little bit
in fact if you turn the page you might
see something familiar on page two
see that bam they're like you guys seem
like you might find these triangles
useful right so you don't even need to
draw them anymore
they're provided to you but the whole
point is what can you get out of them
the triangles are no use if you don't
know how to read them and so can you see
how we read them and got these things
off it
does that make sense any questions on
that before we do this last thing and
then i set you to work again on the
exercise
okay so that was exact values um one
more subheading and then i promise i'll
shut up
and that is reciprocals reciprocals
so um
the trigonometric ratios right like say
sine i keep coming back to sine because
everything's built off a sign
it's opposite of hypotenuse quite often
in the kinds of problems you have to
solve
you might not want opposite on
hypotenuse you might actually want it
the other way around
right you might want hypotenuse on
opposite that's a reciprocal
right now these don't come up as often
as sine cos and tan
but they come up enough that they get
their own names things don't get named
unless it's like oh this is useful right
so each of these three
signed cos and tan its reciprocal has
its own
name does anyone know at least one of
them don't give me all of them
give me one sec all right so sec
theta we can all jot that down sec theta
is the reciprocal so it's one over one
of the ratios which one now i'm going to
teach you a little trick which is
i wish there were a reason for this it
is completely coincidental but you know
what i'm just going to take it anyway
to work out which one is which just have
a look at the one two
three the third letter of this
particular ratio sec what's the third
letter
it's a c so sec is the reciprocal of
cosine because it's c for cos
so for instance uh what do we got here
so we got
cos theta here sorry cos 30 degrees if i
said sec
of 30 degrees it would just mean take
the reciprocal of that in this case
2 over e3 that's it there's nothing
crazy and weird about it it's just
giving me the reciprocal
can someone give me another reciprocal
functionality matter you gave me once
that's good does anyone else know any
others
okay go for it cosec all right so
you're probably getting suspicious you
know how this sine and cosine well
there's sec
and cosec we'll do the same thing look
at the third letter in this case it's an
s so it is a handy way to remember that
it is the reciprocal of
s4 sine right
so if for example sine 30 degrees is 1
over
2 then cosec of 30 degrees would be
2 over 1 which is 2. this one last one
you want to give it to us it's caught
uh and one last time i mean there's only
one last option but just
so it's you know for consistency if you
look at that third letter
it's a t so we're going to have the
reciprocal of
10 it's the only one left so you get the
idea when you move a little further into
this exercise it's going to ask you for
a sec
of this angle or cosec of that angle
right and this is all they mean
on your calculator there is no sec or
cosec or cot
button so if you for example let's we
already know what this is equal to
can you go to your calculator and type
in 1 over
sine of 30 degrees we already know what
the answer will be
but just verify that you're getting it
right 1 over sine 30 it tells you 2
right because it's just doing the
reciprocal of a half so
if you ever see a question that asks you
this just think oh
in my calculator i'm gonna have to turn
it upside down and then off i go
okay